okay I'm gonna do very quick
introductions we have with us Henry
Olsen Mike Frank and Mary Katharine ham
I know Henry Olsen I've known for a long
time so if I wanted to give anyone an
introduction I could go on for 10 or 15
minutes about Henry I won't be unfair to
the other two I will say I had to give a
couple of presentations of my own last
week in California and every only thing
people wanted to ask was what's gonna
happen in the midterms and I had a very
short answer to that I don't know go
read Henry Olsen it's an effective
answer and I think it was also good for
the audience in that I was I didn't
mislead them so I have a four-part I'm
just gonna begin with a it sounds
ambitious but I think it's it's it's the
right question it's a four-part question
you can all answer and it gives you a
latitude to kind of say whatever you
want whatever is on your mind
who won part 1 part 2 who lost part 3
what happened that you expected that you
saw coming and what part 4 is what was
unexpected or surprising and we'll just
go in the order that were seated so
Henry why don't you go first
despite everything that's been thrown
against him you take a look at the map
the Trump coalition held together in
every state that he won with the
exception of Michigan and Pennsylvania
that only a slight improvement
in Wisconsin and Trump is reelected
president and that's an approval rating
of 44 percent because the Trump
coalition came out for somebody else
besides Donald Trump are the Democrats I
would be very very worried about that I
think that what happened that the most
of the night happened according to my
pre-election prediction memo so I wasn't
very surprised about much that the
election is basically a battle between
the importance of what I called in the
memo rhinos and tigers rhinos
Republicans the name only or the reason
why the Democrats took the house that
people who are who were in the early
part of this decade the left wing of the
Republican Party are now in revolt
against the new party leadership and
they are voting with their old enemies
Democrats and that's why karen handel
who represents a suburban scene in
Atlanta that written army won like 23
points lost is because one in every five
of those voters or basically 1/10 or 1/6
of those voters have switched parties
but the Tigers are Trump is great
Republicans they are the blue-collar
former Democrats and they came out to
that what saved the Republican Party's
bacon is that they came out for people
who weren't on top and if you take a
look at the Senate seats in the Midwest
that the Democrats lost if you just look
at the cities and the suburbs and
compare it to their winning margin six
years ago they should have won the
election if the elections in Mississippi
were about Kansas City Springfield
Columbia st. Louis Curtin Claire
McCaskill comes back the reason she
loses by six points is because small
town in rural Missouri comes out against
her and that's people who are normally
Republican and that gets the last thing
that did surprise me which was all of
the data going into the race suggested
that we Republicans would lose more
Obama Trump voters or Tigers than
was optimal and instead even though they
weren't getting picked up in the polls
or they remind pollsters they came home
and that's why Mike DeWine is governor
that's why we picked up the number of
Senate seats and that was probably the
most pleasant surprise of the evening
okay thank you talk about a wave I don't
think it happens in one cycle I think
it's been an ongoing thing extra series
of red wave going back problem to early
2000s when different kinds of elites
started to gravitate in increasing
numbers and I think this election might
have completed that sort you took all
congressional districts I'm obsessed
with this the last two years of study
this stuff helps my career's know these
matters so you can kind of look at the
demographic see well that explains why
congresswoman so so said this is said
that
No and basically if you tell me a little
bit about demographics such as mean home
value or the percentage of households in
the district that have become two
hundred and over percentage of people in
district for military veterans or
working positions or training or in the
middle I can give you within eighteen
eighty percent of chance of success
district what kind of thing that
happened on Tuesday along those lines
and basically see is that at the highest
Democratic coalition now it's at the
highest and the elite measures income
education home values that kind of thing
in the looks side so they have the book
they have both extremes in their
representative in does Republicans have
been pursuits and so on
high levels of currently married status
and what happened before is that what
was stopping never being a complete
sorting is that a lot of districts would
have a lot of the high-end elites and a
lot of people in the middle and not very
many so the underclass category and that
was so let's go to the firewall for
Republicans to keep a lot of the
suburban seats that firewall went away
on Tuesday and if you
suburban districts net flip they were
all kinds of metro areas locking were
the high-end Southern California la of
the Metro some remaining parts of I
think of the East Coast get a few away
you have in Chicago we have some of
those but you also had more moderate
income level of suburban areas that same
thing happened to so the Minneapolis st.
Paul the more the more wealthy areas was
Virginia they've all started looking
into had been kind of resistant to that
trend for over a decade and then Tuesday
I think so now you have a situation
where compared to when I was growing up
and get involved in this stuff it was
very credible that they qualify was say
Republicans with the party the richness
hearing it and he's a little speaks
today Jerry Denham and tearing down
apparently brilliantly it is
constitutional expert earnings future
chair and now the judiciary committee
was having a very vocal conversation
Washington in New York 22 you know this
an old this has now been a genre for
some time the Acela conversation the
overheard a cell a conversation that
becomes a column so many people have
been bitten in the behind by it over the
years I'm surprised anybody is still so
indiscreet to have that kind of
conversation but thank god they are
because it makes for very entertaining
reading mary catherine
wouldn't Esther be in my theory is the
one exception yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i these districts are literally made to
be representative of the area they come
from if they're for nationalizing the
boat would iterate the reason for the
reducing so it didn't
[Music]
interesting but I will caution that this
continued sorting despite this victory
and we're made
it's
[Music]
so you you answered my next question so
I'll just very briefly asked two of you
what you thought I was gonna say was
there Cavanagh effect how was it larger
or smaller than you anticipated or you
know I you it was the thing that gave
Republicans hope I don't know it seems
like 10 years ago but it was probably
only about 6 weeks ago this was gonna
turn everything around
seem to be doing so for a while then it
seemed to ever way Wow what would you
say that
- sent a little that you know I did not
see it's certainly Republican enthusiasm
numbers hopped up after that but I tend
to believe that love a lot of people
vote whether they say they're
enthusiastic or not I think it certainly
helped with bringing out the marginal
Republican - I think a lot of them would
have voted anyway I think it was part of
what brought the Obama Trump voter back
but I also think the president's for the
president is the only Republican and
national leadership who understands
those voters and talking about making
sure that NAFTA deal got done before the
midterm matter enough have to do is
talking about immigration matter and I
do think the the Cavanaugh thing helped
but perhaps as much in that the over
outsized unanimous freakout that was on
display for about ten days probably
reminded the Obama Trump voter that this
is not their grandfather's democratic
right well and I think beyond that the
Cavanaugh thing brought out and made a
different kind of voter respond frankly
a voter like me who was not a trump
voter who went oh this is what we're up
against reminder this is what we're up
against and I had obviously you see I
think you saw it in the numbers too but
since the plural of anecdote is data
I had several I did have several friends
particularly well educated women friends
moms who live in the suburbs the exact
kind of voter that we're losing that
during the Kavanagh thing were texting
me saying you know what I kind of been
out of the game for like two years and
this is ridiculous like I'm back in and
that that meant something to me and to
me it was a very two-track messaging
thing where the Cavanaugh thing brought
in those voters and
sort of somewhat ironically some of the
immigration messaging seemed perfectly
tailored to me to turn exactly those
voters off and back home but what it did
speak to is the Obama Trump voter right
and so having a two-track message like
that is very tricky you don't know what
you're losing and what you're gaining
but there were two things going on there
and two types of voters who were
responding to it so keying off on
something else that you said that Mary
Catherine said on the one hand you know
the party of power tends to get
slaughtered in a midterm when you don't
get slaughtered there's a tendency to
breathe a sigh of relief maybe feel a
little euphoria you did you know
Republicans didn't lose Texas they
didn't lose the Georgia governorship
we'll see what happens in Florida but
maybe you know the worst was averted on
the other hand should we be should
Republicans be concerned that look at
when you have to sweat out a race in
Texas of all things of Georgia against
fairly left-wing candidates these are
people not running as you know a
Democrat of fifteen years ago
a sort of blue dog type does that
portend a different future coming and
this was just a reprieve the Republican
Party before Trump was a minority
coalition that was the conservative
business conservatives where I know
coalition
minority it was not appealing to
potential voters and it was and every
four years it would become smaller
because of demographic change trump has
created a new minority coalition one
that can elect because of where these
sorters live president but also does not
represent the majority of the voters
what you have to do is find a way to put
that rhinos and the tigers together in
one party and that is something I think
may be hard for Trump to do although I
can imagine ways that he could try and
do it about this one that would
definitely is the only way to put
together a national coalition to pull
back the research and left and it's not
the one that can be put together neo the
Rotarians because it requires acceptance
of government and actually an embrace of
some degree of limited government
intervention to help average people
pursue opportunity when they don't have
the resources more than there are in the
case of women and discrimination serious
obstacles in their way which question
are we asking right now should we be
worried about the near loss of places
that used to be solidly red yes and this
is the this is the trick as the
balancing act right and it's and it's
very hard to do I was struck by the fact
that somebody like a stacey abrams she
wasn't really hiding the fact that she
was progressive and this is georgia so
that's interesting to me and I think her
her superpower such that it was she did
not win but like the way she was able to
run closer I think is that she did not
allow Trump to drive her insane and very
few Democrats have the super power
particularly progressives they are so
tempted to run as far left as possible
to get all the money to get all the
accolades to get all the Twitter likes
and it's very easy to do that and feel
like you're killing it except you're not
actually talking to voters and I thought
she was actually sort of surprisingly
disciplined at times like
Jake Tapper the other day I was watching
asked her about some of trumps comments
specifically about her not being
qualified and I expected her to lecture
him to say he's a bad person to do some
race stuff possibly she goes immediately
to like let me tell you what my
qualifications are and she's aiming that
message at the suburban white educated
woman voter there's plus for us which is
that not many of them have that talent
right not many progressives can can
figure out that they need to be talking
to voters and not just a progressive
fundraisers and people who will donate
to them online it's a very different
game but I do think I do think we need
to be worried and we need to be working
hard to try to hit this balance in a way
that does not turn off the RINO suburban
woman who is necessarily it should be a
part of your community and should be you
know somebody you're trying to reach
partly because our policies are good for
them right
not just the not just the game so it
does worry me and it worries me because
I think there is a there's an age
problem that we have to and the the
numbers of young people who came out to
vote we're very serious for a midterm
and you cannot rely in the same way you
used to on people growing up and
becoming conservative just because once
those patterns are locked in as they are
in California before they moved to Texas
it's hard to overcome them and I I worry
that where we're putting up too many
barriers to actually closing that gap at
least a little bit before those guys are
in their 30s and 40s and really locked
in
which makes it all the more delicious
[Music]
this is some ways a normalization of
which is another thing maybe more than
to talk about Trump in New Orleans
context talk about what school or policy
churches he fits into the left
so I think we're about to go to the
audience
shortly but I have two more questions
and you can either answer both our form
one or neither whatever you want one of
them is about the election one of us
more of a look forward picking up again
with something very catherine said so
the election question is look Denver one
party held the house for forty years
prior to 1994 and if you take out the
the sort of Truman anomaly the ante
Truman anomaly you have to go back to
the New Deal so it's really seventy year
control now we've seen this
extraordinary volatility in the house
where it changes hands in a way that is
if not unprecedented in American history
you have to go back a long long time
what are the prospects do you see any
prospect for one or the other party to
lock back in long term control of the
house or are we gonna see do the
Republicans have a realistic chance of
taking it again in the near term even in
two years or if not in two years in you
know four years eight years six years
and then the other question is this is
less about yesterday or but more about
the result of yesterday so it seems to
me the Democrats it's not an original
insight I just want to get your take on
it there in kind of a bind right the
same people you're talking about the
right to fundraising letters and do all
that stuff they demand I mean they just
demand impeachment it has to happen
sooner rather than later immediately you
know probably if there are any cooler
heads in the Democratic leadership they
may see that that's not the best course
to follow immediately they might
remember 1998-99 they know that a
conviction is impossible and they also
maybe they have the things that they
want to do with these two years rather
than swallow them up entirely with an
impeachment that is gonna go nowhere so
what are they how do they how do they
walk that that line without you know
provoking a mutiny among their base but
without also just turning off these
voters in the middle who would see
impeachment is folly and futile
we are as more finely balanced between
the two parties and since the period
between 1876 and 1896 when the south
voted Democrat the North Dakota
Republican and there were sort of swing
states and the era when there was lots
of partisan change and nobody got 50% of
them what broke that was when one party
moved outside of a mainstream and the
other party was shrewd enough to capture
and that was the Democrats with William
Jennings Bryan Republicans by making
themselves the party of capital and
labour simultaneously and I think the
party that does that the party that can
figure out how to put together the two
swing groups in American hit in American
politics today the upscale suburban I
and the downscale worker married with
their base is the party that will run
things for ten years and set the tone
for the ensuing decade it's not clear
that either party's base leadership
knows how to do it and it's not clear
that either party's base really wants to
do it and that's one reason why we keep
having these wild swings you know we
actually probably have more 25 seat
swings in the house over the past decade
than at any period in the last century
and that's precisely because we use a
tennis analogy the serve passes to one
party and then they double fall and it
goes back to the other
five to 3233 yeah whoever gets in the
journey is giving such a narrow majority
that they don't make the house even less
functional today in fact now the
majority to take away any excuse that
they can satisfy the demands of your
face so it's not just impeachment it's
Medicare for all you want to have a fun
policy discussion get Medicare for all
moving through the committee's and
getting to the point of being ready that
would be loaded in the house federal
work every single worker who loses for
her health card right and some be thrown
into Medicare every military you know
family same thing every person in the
private sector that gets their coverage
to work same thing so I think that why
steeping the Democratic right do not
want the part that demands at their face
to actually become any form of reality
get into that legislative dance instead
of moving forward but I think the
margins getting large enough that they
will not be able to be looked at their
base and saying wait two more years give
us two more years we really build on
majority
in a president and get the Senate back
and so on so would you expect that to
cost them in 2020 yeah I have both
recency bias and my own personal bias
because volatility has been the name of
the game essentially my entire political
coming of age so I think it's likely
here to stay I will say that moving the
Republican Party is the fact that during
the Obama years all of those state
legislature seats for Democrats were
wiped out and local legislators and all
that or local figures and all that stuff
meaning that our bench is surprisingly
deep and so it may mean that we have a
bunch of people who can thread the
needle coming up who have have had
careers that have had practice and
Democrats will have fewer of them
because they haven't been in office
because we beat them so interesting for
the future of House races and that kind
of thing I do think Trump and the
Republican Party's greatest allies are
the economy and Democrats acting insane
those are the two things that will
really lead to wins for us and Donald
Trump has a truly amazing talent of
making his adversaries act like their
worst selves at all times
it is it is remarkable and they all
sailor although the problem I have with
this president is he's destroying norms
and disrespecting institutions and so in
order to fight him I am going to destroy
some norms and disrespect some
institutions like that's guys this is
not the way to go about doing this
but because he has this power I fully
expect House Democrats to continue to
succumb to it and because their base
will require it of them and because
despite the fact that Nancy Pelosi gave
actually quite a quite a decent speech
the other night in which
she did not go after Trump because she
knew that wasn't the answer she's still
Nancy Pelosi and she will remain the
speaker because she wouldn't even walk
away when they were getting wiped out
she's like now I'm just gonna stay in
charge guys so she's not gonna do it now
there is no viable alternative she will
remain a figure who improbably I thought
it would stop working but it hasn't
stopped working she continues to bring
Republicans out and to and to make
people think that things like to vote
based on her so they will continue to be
the be their worst selves politically
speaking and strategically speaking and
and that will likely lead to 20/20
victory for Trump I think I I just have
seen no evidence that there they're
gonna Connor Lam this 2020 thing they're
gonna have 27 people and they're all
gonna be fighting to be as crazy as
possible and the thing that I've been
amazed of DIN 2016 and 2018 now at CNN I
was at Fox before and the extent to
which and this goes for many people in
this in this city it's a cliche at this
point but the extent to which they
people do not understand that people see
things differently there than they do
here in this obsession with Trump's
character and Trump's actions and
Trump's tweets it just does not read the
same out in other states right and they
cannot get that through their heads and
I think that continued chasm will also
lead to the probability of victories in
the future for Republicans okay so we're
gonna turn it over to the audience now
when we have people with microphones so
you have to go up sir in the front here
let's wait for the mic
thank you I'll have us a great talk you
were talking about futures and made some
comment about the Republicans being
older but when I look at the future and
see what the Democrats are proposing for
possible presidential candidates I'm
looking at people that are generally
seventy years and older which is fine
I like those people I aspire to be one
of those people one day I can identify
with those people but that looks like a
weak bench to me when Joe Biden is being
tossed as as the most competitive member
of the Democratic Party he's gonna be
what 76 77 and when he'd run I think
he's 74 75 now and where's the strength
in is there any strength in the
Democratic Party I hope the answer's no
but that might constitute a real threat
to which I would add for the panel's
consideration not only I agree with the
premise but you know the Republicans we
thought it was absurd and unhelpful to
have 17 primary candidates in 2016 what
I'm hearing now would speculate and
we'll see what actually happens is the
Democrats might have 30 to 35 at least
initially audition for the role maybe
they don't get to the first debate
podium but what what do you foresee on
that side and turn polls on both the
strength inventions just to sheer
numbers
I think one thing I do not think that
any of the curve frontrunners it's gonna
be the nominee
I don't think Biden's gonna be the
nominee I don't think Warren's gonna be
the nominee
I don't think seniors it's going to be
the nominee I think they are going to
find somebody who is not 70 years or
older and I think they are likely to
nominate a woman that is not an accident
that there are going to be 99 Democratic
women in the house because 62 percent of
the primary electorate of the Democratic
Party is female when you put that
together with the rising power of
non-whites I think you have to
Kamala Harris a very strong offered
chance of being the nominee and I think
you also have to look and see whether or
not a woman will emerge on the less
progressive side you know I think that
somebody like Amy Klobuchar who kudos
for her non hysterical or not I'm sorry
but I'd be thrown off of CNN for that
word none emotionally charged questions
for Democrats who would look like to
fight fire with fire but still when
somebody who's a liberal who by the way
has won her state in the Midwest and
knows how to talk to Midwestern voters I
think she could and I think she could
find a strong showing so I do not think
that one of the dinosaurs is going to
leave their part okay yes sir I'll just
wait for the microphone thank you
I was staring a little bit of an
exaggerated metaphor to make my question
situation I was pretty good with pretty
evenly balanced and all that good stuff
but the Democrats have two big nuclear
rockets who are already flying one is
called Louis Q immigration and the other
one is called identity politics and all
we have against this is Howard bows and
arrows of economic talk and political
philosophy talk about opportunities and
so I'm looking and I'm thinking isn't it
time for us to see that we have to
develop our own identity politics ever
has to develop our own I mean great well
immigration already the president has
seen that but I think the work of Dinesh
D'Souza has been amazing of basically
retelling the history of this country
and retelling the role of the Democratic
Party and of the Republican Party and
building a new idea because if you think
about Trump that's my question actually
I think the biggest thing about Trump is
that he had the courage to call them bad
people we've been living in this country
forever and I'm an immigrant but they
call us bad people all the time
all the isms all the and we have
basically accepted to liberate he was
the first one who called him back
bad people fake news whatever so I in
real do you see something along those
lines rephrase the question slightly and
that you know maybe not so much the
Republicans need to adopt identity
politics so I'm gonna rephrase it in an
answer at least gave my own answer but
do they need to find a way to answer and
come up with an antidote to identity
politics I think he answers absolutely
and they haven't done it Trump is the
first to at least begin to find a way it
seems to me in part because he doesn't
immediately accept the premise of
attacks on him which most Republicans do
but I'd like to hear what you all have
to say I'm starting excuse me
yeah I mean I think part of the power of
Trump is that he smashes the paradigm
right and it's because he's willing to
say no no you guys are bad actors like
this is not you can't come at me with
this when you're doing when you're doing
this and like yes I think I rant that
plenty of Republicans have played too
nice on this front in the past and I
think there's a ton of merit in the fact
it cracks me out that people sort of
look back with rose-colored glasses to a
pre-jump era like politics was like
really doing great before and I'm like
no that the way we did politics before
is what created robot Rubio that moment
where a very talented politician and
talker and an interesting person got
stuck in this rut because they've been
all been taught I can't I can't veer
from the message I have to say this over
and over and over again
well Trump just came along was like oh
yeah you want to you want to see gaffes
I got gaffes I could gasp for days and
they just can't focus on one right so
just sort of the whole machine sort of
starts sputtering and smoking and
there's merit to that so I think I think
that's really powerful and I think that
a lot of people underestimate the extent
to which Trump is a response to the left
in this country telling really good
people that they're the problem with
America
like responsible people just raising
families and working you are the problem
with America your trash your probably
racist and sexist yeah you're deplorable
and the extent to which he was a
response to that I think still people
under underestimate and the joke with
liberal friends that uh you know if
you're worried about like reaching out
to Trump voters the good news is that
like 99% of them are nicer than Trump
and what they said was like I'm not mean
enough to be this guy but I'm gonna hire
this guy to be me mean for me and that's
a real part of this Ronnie got 61 and
then truncated 67 and I know what
percentage that qualifies are proved to
be an identity politics crew you know
but the Democrats have long had these
very high margins african-americans
obviously been around 95 percent more
and Asians and Hispanics 75 to 80
percent so now all the sudden a group is
a lot larger than those groups starting
to look around and say well maybe this
room is empty in that of these other
folks and we're the ones who are left
here and this guy's telling us very HS
said that it's a very you know what
you're suffering and so on and so maybe
that's one reason is a victory
instructor sir grade is that the
offending politics monster is turned on
the Democratic Party
maybe that's the beginning of getting
rid of it maybe that realization at some
point was a you know the same working
fundamentally whenever American politics
shifts and it does shift new coalition's
are formed and define an age every 30 or
40 years or living through death now the
argument is always what does it mean to
be in America
what is our revolutionary heritage mean
for today and the Democrats answer is in
order to be truly free in order to be
truly include everybody we have to
divide everybody into trucks and it's if
the Republican answer is the same on my
tracks bigger that's not actually an
answer I think the answer that people
want that is is an answer that says we
can all be part of something that we can
be proud of and so when Trump Trump is
never going to be the person who does
that but at the heart of everything that
he pushes is that sense of whether we
betray what means to be in America and
we need to get that right again and I
think Trump successor will be the person
who can successfully articulate what is
inchoate and present in Trump which he
does not in fact articulate oh sorry I
have a comment and then maybe a
follow-up question just on that I sort
of see what you're saying that Trump
will never be the person to do that if
that's just because of his you know
colourfulness bombastic as he turns off
to many people although he does speak
exactly the language that you're talking
about when he talks about nationalism
yeah you know this I he's accused of
white nationalism and other things which
is completely preposterous every time he
opens his mouth and talks about this
subject
maybe I was gonna say he sounds exactly
like Abraham Lincoln that's probably
going too far in terms of in terms of
the actual words and the rhetoric used
but the thoughts are the same
they're identical to the way Lincoln
expressed the idea of citizenship so I
know maybe maybe the party needs a
different spokesperson but he has shown
the way you look at these white collar
people except this is before in the
general election what drives the truck
Republican coalition was citizenship
yeah but what Trump will never do unless
he has somebody who gets his mind and is
also skillful than words his Trump is
never the sort of person who's going to
be able to make the argument from A to B
and know how to put that argument in the
middle of all of the situations radium
could because Reagan wrote his own
philosophy and wrote it and scripts
Trump's got the ideas but it's going to
require either somebody to do it for him
who understands them and can put them
into an argument form or somebody after
him who gets all of the things that he
gets but has a storytelling narrative
argumentation ability okay so leads me
to the question that I wanted to ask
which is I've been going around saying
sort of more maybe hopefully then it's
in certainty but we all know it doesn't
take a whole lot of the black or the
Hispanic vote for Trump to carve away
from the Democrats and they have a
serious problem I think it's also fair
to say demographically black and
Hispanic voters are much more likely to
be on the blue-collar side low income
side or at least the working-class side
then the the old parts of the Republican
coalition what are the prospects for a
kind of trans ethnic transracial Trump
appeal to blue-collar voters that
doesn't capture let's say majorities of
black and Hispanic voters but let starts
to get seriously into the 20s would be
enough to be a grave danger to Democrats
I mean how likely do you think that
prospect is
it's like we're gonna happen among
Hispanics there's among blacks but
that's the future of the pre Trump
Republican Party dealt with the fact
that whites are shrinking share of
America
in two mutually destructive ways was the
business wing saying basically all these
people are being entrepreneurs and all
we have to do is you know get rid of the
parts of our party which just happened
to be the conservatives and now I guess
and the other is you know the Koch
brothers all we have to do is educate
them all about the wonderfulness of
opportunism and over here actually these
people are working-class people they
were the best people those all did
opportunity and security they want our
government strong enough to keep them
safe from harm a lot of government that
is respectful enough against the heck
out of the way I think to embrace that
aspect of trial from a third of nine
percent of the black folk to twenty or
twenty five percent and that would
destroy the Democratic Party judges can
I just add that they were already sort
of seeing this pre midterms among in the
Hispanic numbers and getting worried
because it did not look like they would
turnout in mass and they were not as
turned off by Trump as everyone assumed
they should be right and that's part of
what I mean about people seeing things
so differently here like obviously
Hispanics would hate him in huge numbers
and if you look at the numbers that's
not actually that true and if you really
want to blow their minds remind them at
the midterms same point in this
presidency for Obama Trump's numbers
with Hispanics in several polls were
like maybe five points lower
I mean it's remarkable it's remarkably
close so there's already ground there
that you could that you could work on I
do it does concern me as you've know
definitely Trump's not the guy who goes
to that room and makes that argument
successfully and there's an alternative
history where I wish he was slightly
different and more capable of doing that
do you think there are people
particularly blue-collar black and
Hispanic men that he could he could win
over if he did up if you put in a little
bit of work on that I think you still
have the issue of minority women
combined with suburban white
college-educated women
you put those two groups together who
are fairly turned off by Trump in many
ways and you got a problem if you're not
reaching them as well even if you're
able to maybe who are more assimilated
into our culture those who might be more
segregated from and maybe speaking in
manage might be one marker that and then
only can get that group
maybe that's going to look like what
happened to Italians and Irish in
politics so at some point okay I think
we have time for one more question yes
me my quick take on it is it seems like
it's different than has been in the past
because the polarization is
multi-dimensional comes in to a lot of
different areas I don't think you used
to be able to look at someone's
educational and predict a whole lot of
other markets as well so that's a pretty
deep you know okay well please join me
in thanking our panelists
[Applause]